uh thank you guys for being here with us
and mike i have some information for you
that i think you're going to find
very very interesting so
that's some new info on the associated
associate d.i.d
of course um with her british teeth she
is hot but those look at those teeth
yeah those teefers are not the best but
i mean you would all right
so yeah i mean so only when she only
when she's kyle though
i want her to be kyle the whole thing
bro let's suck
anytime she turns into kyle like when
she goes to take a piss or something
does she start screaming
ah we're like you're right wouldn't you
he said
so she has for those who don't know
again on our clip channel you can find
um all our videos on her
and she has multiple personality are now
known as dissociative identity disorder
which we respect highly here on the show
which is a made-up white woman disease
or that and
um so did you know
that she has a tear in her patreon
um where you can speak to one of her
alters now you can only speak to one
this is true this is not made up
you could speak to one of our alters
kyle so you have a 15 minute
conversation with kyle
uh skype call to 15 minute skype call
with kyle how much do you think
she charges 15 minutes uh 100 bucks
300 are you kidding me no this is right
it's weird
it's again she's so good at i mean i got
to give her props for this
she's so good at planning around
these these these different
personalities showing up it's weird yeah
like she how do you know kyle's going to
be around enough to to do these
i actually know how because she's lying
oh okay that meant well i made
you know when you put it like that royce
yeah so it's
dollars that's 300 it's 300
and you get to speak to kyle uh and
she's making this new video this is even
lauren southern only charged like 250
and she has better teeth so uh this is
uh jade this is jade speaking
of better grift
[Laughter]
so this is um this is jade
uh she this is her her jj [ __ ] this
chick has
her teeth look like [ __ ] captain
crunch it's really
bad dude it's really all [ __ ] alan
powell teeth over here
so let's um let's play this
this this is important uh
check this out this is jade welcome back
to another video by dissociated this is
jade
and today hi jade we are going to be
answering questions
that were given to us by our patrons and
they have a question why are you a liar
they asked us to make a video on what my
role is like
as gatekeeper of the system jade is the
gatekeeper
kyle's the protector jade is the gay why
are you allowed to do this but we're not
allowed to just make
fun of people as a joke because you know
what i mean this is a disease
a made up one royce it's yes it's a
made-up one
[Music]
cool intro dude
a gatekeeper alter is an altar
that can have i'm a gatekeeper
i am the key master gets punched by a
black guy my name is vince clarke and i
want to [ __ ] your mouth
it's roles within a system mainly
they either are able to control who has
access
to what memories or who has access to
the front
sometimes if there is a switch that
needs to happen or somebody who needs to
be blocked from the front
a gatekeeper alter may be more able than
other alters
to control who has that access and who
does this does not sound scientifically
accurate
do you remember the good old days
when when like when somebody spoke like
this
you could just call the authorities and
go
this person clearly needs to be put away
and work on their issues remember those
days remember how cool that was
doesn't my role is less like that in my
system
my role is more to do with memories
and controlling and removing memories
and i bet you if you lock this [ __ ] up
in one of those terrible gross
by the way it's england so it would be
one of those hms
[ __ ] mental health places which i'm
sure it was built in 1650
they look like arkham asylum
but i bet you you put her in one of
those british arkham asylum type
hospitals
i will bet you cash money
that she's cured within a month oh yeah
i agree with you
no i'm better now i'm better can i leave
can i please leave
i promise i'll never do my made-up
disease thing again
i guarantee you lock her in a [ __ ]
mental health facility for a month and i
guarantee you by the end of that month
she'll be like
i was i was grifting i was lying i'm
sorry can i leave now
so for example if nin or in the past
chloe
were to have a flashback that they
weren't ready to handle yet
that we as a system were not ready for
the repercussions of yet
i am responsible for removing that
memory from her consciousness
that's not to say that this is always
successful and it's not an easy thing to
do but i do have control of memory
filing
i'm awesome memory filing
mind palaces this
this one month one [ __ ] month and
she'd come out and go i'm sorry i was
lying
please can you please let me go now also
able to control who accesses what areas
of the inner world
some gatekeepers the inner world
see because there's two things there's
there's two things
when it comes to um
mental health facilities because they're
not pleasant places to be
um the one one purpose that they serve
is that if you do have some sort of
dangerous like schizophrenia or
something
and you're danger to people or you're
criminally insane
they can treat you they can keep you in
a place where you're safe and all that
stuff
the other side the one that people don't
ever talk about is that they serve as a
deterrent
so that we are not glorifying mental
illness and using it in order to
gain victim points run gofundme scams
see if we had mental health facilities
and certain criteria at which you could
put them in mental health facilities
people like this would be too scared to
ever do this
because they'd be like well no people
are going to think i'm nuts they're
going to put me in a nutty house
but now that there's no now you can
pretend to be crazy you could pretend to
have a disease
there are no penalties they can't make
you go to any kind of a thing if you
don't want to go
and then you could just make a bunch of
money so there's really no reason now
not to just lie about your mental
illness
it was may literally gatekeep within the
inner world
control who can access what subsystems
or what structures in the inner world
perhaps they may guard specific objects
or alters
i guard all of these things i control
who has access to the dungeons
who has access to the carousel who has
access to the basement
and no what acts as the dungeon you have
to put a bomb in front of the cave
and it like blows the cave open and then
you get a sword yeah but that's legend
of zelda rules
oh okay because there's other ways to
access caves just depending on the game
you're right sometimes you can't even
get into the cave until you you know
actually
get to the the land that has the cave a
lot of times i'll cut you off that way
everybody has access beyond the carousel
except me
and one of our persecutors demon only
demon and i
are able to access the carousel this is
just demon demon could access the
carousel
of progress again they're going around
and they're rounding up people
and putting them in jail and putting
them in health facilities for having
barbecues at their house right
but this woman's allowed to just do this
and there's no
there's no nobody comes nobody comes and
does a welfare check
because if if somebody
let's say that uh this young lady here
isn't a complete [ __ ] lying piece of
[ __ ]
let's say that i mean she is that
but let's say she's not for a second if
your family member
was talking like this if your sister was
talking like this
wouldn't you be concerned enough to go
we need to do something of course i
don't you know what i mean like she
could hurt herself
she could hurt kids around her who knows
but if you're talking like this
and you mean it then clearly it's like
we
need to do something before somebody
gets hurt or we regret not
stepping up and doing something um you
wouldn't glorify it and go you know what
we should do we should exploit this
for a youtube channel and make money off
of it
like this this woman in addition to
being a [ __ ] completely full of [ __ ]
grifter
um also doesn't seem to have anybody
around that cares about her in any way
well to add them to what you said that's
a very good point if this is true you
wouldn't let her drive a car
you don't know i can't you can't you you
you would what if you turn what if
you're one of your altar turns into one
of your littles that doesn't know how to
drive you're gonna kill a pedestrian
like
yeah at what level do you go okay this
isn't we can't do this what if one of
your altars is
you know they're gonna let her just go
driving a car all willy-nilly
there is a door that floats in the
center of the carousel to everybody else
this door looks black
okay me and demon this door looks red
and we are able to pass through it
what there's a magic door now
i live in a cave and it is my home
i'm not ashamed of it i guard the mouth
of the king by the way i just want to
point out because many one in the chat
says then pitier but don't do not rat
her out
there's no but here's the thing dude
it's not ratting out
it's not rotting out it's like patrice
o'neill said an interview years ago he
was talking about
people always use this expression brutal
honesty
like man he's so brutally honest but why
does honest why is honesty brutal
why does it have to be brutal why can't
why isn't
why isn't our perception of honesty the
good thing why is
why is it comforting white lies
comforting lies
but brutally honest like it's not
ratting out it's going
hey hey stupid this is all made up
so you either need to acknowledge it
because here's the thing it's not
ratting out
she's spreading dangerous medical
misinformation
and she's encouraging other people to
emulate her
so what do you mean and he's saying i
wouldn't call the cut nobody said i'm
not saying no it's a cop
cops we said if you were her family yeah
if you if this person was related to you
and she was doing this talking like this
and you thought she truly believed what
she was saying you'd go
i we got to do something because she's
going to hurt herself or others
crash her car like roy said something's
going to happen
and it's like let's nip this in the bud
first
but it's not ratting it you need the
truth dude
more people need the goddamn truth now
more than ever
tunnels beyond the cave which connect to
the basements
and the dungeons i am responsible for
allowing
nobody except those i choose yes i've
played skyrim
and we know i know how the dungeons work
in the caves
and you go down there and you kill the
dragger and then you get it you know
what i mean and then you just after a
while the caves all look the same and
then you're like why did i start playing
skyrim again
if it gets too hard to bring lydia with
you that's fine yeah lydia just
which is she's just basically a a cheat
code with tits yeah
or out i guard and protect the altars
who
are still dormant let's call it
dormant let's say she's trying to talk
like
she puts she's a terrible actress too
she she tries to put on like these
these these are like this is her this is
her no-nonsense ultra like
who are dormant i'm going to speak like
a villain in a movie
like stop [ __ ] stop this [ __ ] this is
i'm almost gonna say nobody buys this
but of course a lot of people do buy
this because a lot of people give money
to her i mean she's a lot of subscribers
so of course a lot of people do buy it
but
why a unusual kind of dormant
different than the kind that the alters
who are in the loft of the manchester
point randy marsh it's convenient as she
has full control over who she chooses
but she can't choose to not have the
disorder
why don't you just stay one person why
don't you
even though you have all these other
alters why don't you just stay one
person because what you're doing is
slowly killing the people who care about
you
so then what happens is is that people
like this then encourage
like this one multiplicity and me they
encourage people like this now
so so what happens is maybe this one's
just a channel about being
so you got any personalities that aren't
uh you know
thick gals this is trisha pattayas
altar it's like weird man
that sucks when you got multiple
personality disorder it doesn't matter
what personality comes out you're still
a
chick so this is another one that's been
inspired by this and now she has a
channel her channel now has 196 000
subscribers it's a
multiplicity in me this is called how
much trauma do you need to have
disassociative identity disorder see
her problem her problem is that
sometimes she
she has lunch but then she switches
personalities and she didn't remember
she had lunch
she has lunch
for again and me giving you the lived
experience
of the id and today we're going to be
talking about the very important
because we put up with a lot of [ __ ] in
this country but british people put up
with even
more [ __ ] than we do i think it's also
like and i don't mean to get so
spurgy but they have created a culture
that makes white people hate themselves
so much
that like white people have to come up
with these weird
these weird ways of being something
other than just a generic white person
like being a generic white person in
2020 in 2021 is
[ __ ] terrible thing to be so everyone
needs to be
a multiple personality two-spirit
unicorn [ __ ] space odyssey demon
like nobody could just be because being
a white guy sucks
frankly be like it does it being a white
guy right now being a white woman right
now
[ __ ] stinks it's terrible so
you know and and white women tend to
have more
bizarre coping mechanisms than men you
know like when men will just drink
themselves to death and work overtime
until they just have a heart attack at
[ __ ] 40. and then that's it
but white women just sit around all day
and go like i'm gonna make up a new
person out leap
i'm coyle now uh dr chill says she has
multiple
dinner disorder so that's uh that's
medically true
she [ __ ] goes to wendy's like within
twice within the hour and they go you
were just here
that was my altar important topic of
trauma
how much of it do you need to have a
disorder like d.i.d
ending the stigma dude
so we'll be breaking it down today
because there is a lot to squish in here
look you're really baiting me here lady
yeah
first a brief glance into the window of
tolerance a lot of
lot to squeeze into this [ __ ] frame
second
what exactly constitutes rumor which we
will define by the current understanding
of aces
look lady i get what you're saying but
take it from me
uh you know it's you see it all the time
society's crumbling and look
i know you think you're the only person
who stepped out there
but you're not and i know plenty of
people who stepped outside them
and they're still able to like maintain
employment
and not make everybody around them
uncomfortable have you tried doing that
[ __ ] most of the people that were on the
howard stern show in the 90s stepped at
them of course sometimes on the show
yeah
adverse childhood experiences both of
these topics probably need their own
video
but we need to have an understanding of
both of these things to answer the
question at hand
how much trauma is enough for d.i.d
and finally we are you're not a medical
expert
why was anyone listening to you i'll
give a quick
summary of everything and also talk a
little bit about which aces that
we've experienced that we feel has
impacted us the most
as human beings we are all unique
individuals which means we all have a
different perception
reaction to and tolerance to stress and
trauma
the window of tolerance is essentially
how much we can personally cope with
something that's traumatic
so why imagine sitting across this on a
date
oh jess will begin work as a mental
health practitioner in the new year
isn't that great that's good so you want
somebody who thinks she's literally 37
[ __ ] people to be telling you what
your problems are
sounds good to me jess has professional
experiences but does not claim
to be a professional on youtube can i
translate that for the audience
jess wants all of you to think she's an
expert and continue to give her money
but she wants to have a disclaimer
so she can she can grift you as an
expert
but still have no responsibility i use
it
when someone experiences a car crash for
example they may never be able to get on
the road again
but somebody else who's been through an
extremely well that's normally because
nick hogan was driving
and he's not going to be able to get on
anything ever again
[Laughter]
by the way you said imagine sitting
across from this at a date yeah but like
in a golden corral not a [ __ ] burn
steakhouse
good point [ __ ] can't afford to feed
this girl and all her altars
crash will just jump back in their car
the next day this
is down to the weird and wonderful world
of the window of tolerance
but you're not a mental health expert
you've admitted to that in this video
what dictates your current window is a
mixture of
genetic and environment this is somebody
who was wikipedia educated these are
people that get educated with wikipedia
and they just kind of repeat buzz
phrases that they heard
all factors every person's window of
tolerance will be unique to them
some person's perception of trauma it's
almost as if they're making it up
you know what's weird you know what's
you know what most
doctors and experts would tell you about
mental illness and
disease and things like that diagnosable
things
is that um despite some slight
variations
um no the symptoms are almost identical
see that's how you identify a disorder
is because the doctor goes what's wrong
with you
and then you list two or three things
and they go oh yeah
no we know what that is because you fit
a certain thing i love how like it
only with the made-up diseases do they
go everyone's
everyone's perspective and situation is
different and unique
no it's not if you have the flu you're
going to go there and they're going to
go
so what's wrong with you going to go i'm
aching i have a fever i'm like
stuffed up i'm coughing a lot yeah you
probably have the flu here's some zip
for max have a nice day
and then 500 people come in and go well
now nowadays they go well it's covered
and we're gonna mark you down as dead
i'm gonna get 17 000
in my pocket but i mean they know what
you have
based on i have bump up up and this and
boop and bop and they go
yeah you have this we'll fix that but
yeah everyone's thing is unique because
they're all making it up as they go
along
and there's no science behind this from
another person's perception of trauma
and therefore people may not necessarily
feel that a certain type of trauma is
severe enough but it's how your brain
reacts that's important
and in childhood how it soothes
thereafter because we learn
our window tolerance why do we give
these people so
i mean i know we're doing it where i
understand we're guilty of it but
we've really built these people up to
the point where they have huge
followings and everyone's like yeah you
go girl you're right
you go girl yeah
it's again attractive white women
are living life with cheat codes it's
it's
it's life with cheat codes and console
commands
it's in easy mode and it's it's there's
there's no
there is no like i almost feel bad for
white attractive women sometimes
because like you guys don't even
experience the human condition
anymore because you don't because you've
been put in a situation where you don't
ever
have to you know what i mean like if
you're a guy
and you're like average looking and
average intelligence
average everything those people
understand the human condition
the suffering to get through to the
other side and accomplish your
goals and do this and white women are
conditioned to
never have to really take part in the
human experiment
and then they just make [ __ ] up and
everybody goes that's [ __ ] brave
here's some money
that's all it is which is why women
frankly should be
trying to get married find a husband and
go be part of a family because when you
just go off on your own and try to do
all this
you you don't you're not playing by the
same rules as men
kaylie kazoo says but i'm ugly then i'm
not talking to you i'm that
if you're an ugly woman or a woman this
does not apply to you because i've seen
how ugly
women get treated and you're like okay
you're all right you get it
but these attractive women that just go
yeah i know i had like 14 personalities
and i have a gateway in my head where
the demon
opens up the doorway and allows my
male uh uh altar to come in and you go
and
that's great you want to get out of here
and go back to my place or
and that's the problem you got like
attractive women just don't understand
the entire human condition